[Musique]
lille avec un masque à mon avis il ya
quelque chose sur son masque vous en
prie installez-vous merci à chacun un
masque personnalisée n'est ce pas le
vôtre nelly veut oui qu'est-ce qu'elle
criait mais c'est le chat qui dit
restons négatifs
rendez vous amoureux
à milan un homme et sa fiancée se
promènent main dans la main sur la
piazza del duomo auprès de la scala le
fameux opéra lui c'est yves bonnet la
vieille dame en les red bull se sont
bien tous les deux instant magique il
décide s'embrasser langoureusement il
retire le masque et la paf des policiers
qui font une antique à monde 2 400 euros
tu ferais quoi s'il te restait trois
jours à vivre je fumerai comme une vache
je picole ray comme un trou et je ferai
beaucoup l'amour mais j'ai besoin voilà
de quelqu'un
quand même tu vois qui montre de
l'intéressant à la personne ça peut pas
que physique
sucer bonbons glaces sorbets succès
ou sommes le truc je sais pas parce que
vous arrivez à lécher du milieu de la
cuillère jusqu'en haut sans bouger la
tête et sanglé la main jusqu'en je sais
pas pourquoi mais je sens que j'ai pas
l'air malin est ce que quand tu t'assois
sur les toilettes futuro l'elysée ouais
ça c'est bien ça c'est bien ça ça te dit
en tout ça c'est le côté spirituel
public c'est là qu'on réfléchisse en
général douala s'est il ya un côté très
spirituelle à fait juste te dire que
dans les toilettes de c'est à vous il ya
les toilettes réservées pour les femmes
et temps en temps les invités masculins
dix ans je peux pas y aller parce que
l'autre est prise et c'est on pourrait
dresser la liste des invités notamment
des invités artistes
il est partout si tu gagnes tu fais quoi
non c'est plutôt si c'était pas ma
copine
j'ai gagné mon pari déjà donc elles
restent elles restent là c'est très
heureux ouais j'aime ça top il faut
m'expliquer ce que c'est le yoga du rire
c'est un médecin indien qui est le
docteur kataria qui a pratiqué
développer une pratique du rire liés à
la respiration il s'est rendu compte qu
en riant en travaillant son diaphragme
et sa respiration et ben les gens à
aller beaucoup mieux
c'est des exercices respiratoires ou des
mises en situation qui provoque beaucoup
à ce commando moi je recommande
c'est vrai que c'est communicatif
monsieur anthony un art qu'on
sentez-vous à prendre pour épouse madame
audrey pts
[Musique]
e
il ya eu un blanc et je savais pas
comment commencer ma phrase est
comme on est chez nous j'ai sorti mon
pantalon
moi je suis ici pour une personne est
normalement quand c'est fini il faut
faire à propos mais ça c'est ce à quoi
est ce un bon du tout aidé à messieurs
bienvenue chez les fous mais il faut
qu'ils se détendent
je ne veux pas manquer toi quand tu
t'attaches à moi par ce soir je sois
parfum
jacob four charmant
pas de soucis mais j'ai pas envie
d'aller leur voiture plus loin
aucun problème je vais pas passer pour
un con
non mais ces trois drôles mais y'a pas
de problème
ne sont ils pas des questions à base de
regret diane mon regret que ce n'était
là sur le canapé on discute en allant
vous regrettez ce que ça me rendait au
pardon oui oui à dire quoi c'est dire
que tu regrettes quelque chose que tu as
fait il est tombé mardi par haykel club
et pour moi un mariage c'est important
et je n'ai pas envie de voir divorcer
dans une semaine
non mais avoue c'est quand même un peu
la cdac le cadre original non elle
serait quoi une enceinte connecter une
plante verte ou un pot de colle un pot
de colle un pot de colle voilà dorine ça
sent la bonne matinée
du genre je te lâche pas bon mais
tellement tu me saoules en soirée je
suis loin de toi c'est un motif aussi
bien loti un motif mais quelle ambiance
je reste sur ma chaise au fond
j'interviens jusqu'aux genoux mais
l'amour poudre cool non c'est waterloo
qu'amoureuse est pas moi il est beau lui
[Musique]
oh
au
deux amis également du tchétchène deux
amis également du chichon visualiser
c'est exact également des tchétchènes
acquis par dont parmi les désirs réservé
aux amis également trois amies également
dû vous retrouvera plus tard merci je me
prépare à tout et surtout au pire donc
comme ça on n'est jamais déçu
et ils n'ont pas marqué des points
aujourd'hui on les cherche bonnes
surprises comme ça
non c'est une bonne nouvelle il y aura
la 4g sur la lune d'ici 2022
noka s'y engage le constructeur a reçu
14 millions de dollars de la nasa pour y
déployer un réseau mobile
le but améliorer la communication des
astronautes et permettre l'installation
d'une base habitable le projet
d'envergure est très commentée en ligne
la 4g arrivera plus tôt sur la lune que
dans la creuse ironise cet internaute
quatre ans après son lancement la sonde
américaine osiris rex a réussi cette
nuit a touché le sol de l'astéroïde et a
collecté au passage un échantillon de
poussière tout ceci a eu lieu très très
loin de nos johanna à 330 millions de
kilomètres de la terre est le but de
l'opération est bien c'est d'analyser
cette poussière et de nous révéler les
ingrédients originel du système solaire